out of just that group of friends I
think there were probably two or three
companies that have reached over five
hundred million dollars in valuation and
I would have been investing when they
were like under five all right let's
talk about angel investing so my angel
investing life started truly about six
years ago seven years ago when I first
moved to San Francisco so I moved to San
Francisco I get a job as a product
manager at a and an ideal lab called
monkey inferno so p.m. kind of a boring
job p.m. but not at a boring company
this was a very interesting company was
a company that builds companies an idea
lab and I was the only product manager
there was only product guy everybody
else was an engineer and I'm making
$120,000 a year and so I don't think of
myself like an investor right 120k
living in San Francisco paying
california taxes you're not like rolling
and money at all I had a little bit of
money saved up from my previous company
but again I didn't think of myself in as
investors so the first thing was the
first lesson of angel investing was
think of yourself as an investor because
those first three or four years I was in
San Francisco I had the opportunity I
was doing mastermind dinners I was
organizing dinners and my friends were
the founders of other companies and you
know if I had just stopped working on my
company if I had stopped quit my job and
all I did was just write 20k checks to
all of those friends it might have been
I might have needed 250k but I would
have turned that into you know at least
five million dollars just off the
success of those friends companies and I
was helping them and I thought a lot of
their ideas were good I thought a lot of
them would succeed I remember I talked
to the founders of calm
early on when calm was struggling they
couldn't even raise their next round you
didn't know what was gonna happen it was
just kind of Alex toiling away and I
remember thinking hey this guy's like
really committed to this and this guy's
really creative and I think he's right
about the world like I think he's right
that a lot of people will want this a
lot of people will want to have more
calm in their life and I think people or
people will meditate and you know there
was a obviously it wasn't clear-cut but
I would have been on that company and I
would have been on six or seven
those companies and several of them did
really well calm now as you know a
multi-billion dollar company so out of
just that group of friends I think there
were probably two or three companies
that have reached over five hundred
million dollars in valuation and I would
have been investing when they were like
under five so the lesson I learned four
years later was why the hell was i
investing these guys companies I
believed in them I had access to them I
just didn't think of myself in his
investor the excuse I gave myself was I
didn't have the capital but the real the
reality was if you are creative enough
if you're resourceful enough if you're
persuasive enough if you're determined
enough you can get capital you can get
any resource you need and so that
actually brings me to my first angel
investment so the next company I got
really excited about fast forward four
or five years I'm still don't you know
have you know millions of dollars in the
bank to go write these checks and I see
this company called lambda school and I
had been thinking about a product like
this or a project like this to go do
myself and when I saw it I was like whoa
this guy's doing a much better version
of what I was thinking might might work
what's something I thought about doing
so I started calling the guy start
talking to him and I told him you know I
want to invest in your company which was
true not a lie I did one invest in his
company but I didn't tell him I've never
invested in any company so I definitely
withheld that and I said tell me about
your company I want to invest and he
started sent you know sharing his slide
deck sharing the materials and I'm like
you know I have to find a way to invest
this company I thought to myself okay I
need to invest 25k in this company okay
no problem I can sell a stock that I own
or I could say I could just take some of
my savings and do this one company was
never gonna be a problem
but with angel investing you need a
portfolio of companies because you're
investing in early-stage startups this
is extremely high risk of failure so in
a portfolio of 10 companies you would
expect some kind of distribution where
you're gonna get four or five of the
companies to go to zero you know two or
three of the companies to return
somewhere between 1 and 3x and then
hopefully you know you end up with one
or two companies that actually break out
and do 10x plus ideally you get to
something that does a thousand X plus or
10,000 X plus
those are the early investors in uber
for example so anyways I always knew I
could invest in one company but I never
you need about 30 bets to really be you
know an angel investor to have a poor
enough of a portfolio we give yourself a
chance to succeed so you know I was
sitting there doing the math and I said
if I need to invest $25,000 in 30
companies I need $750,000 I didn't have
that so that's why I didn't think of
myself as an investor but what I did was
very smart I kind of give myself credit
on this one when I knew I want to invest
in lambda school I said okay how do I
get the money to invest in this and so I
talked to a friend and I said who I knew
invest and I said hey at this company
that I think is really great I want to
introduce you to them and in general I
see a bunch of companies that are really
interesting and I know you like to
invest do you want to do a deal where
you know I can sort of be a scout I can
be a sort of a venture partner an
entrepreneur who can help you with your
investments and we can set up a deal so
here's what you know the first deal we
set up was cool any deal we invest in I
get 10% carry meaning I don't have to
put any capital in I take zero financial
risk and I get 10% of the upside after
he's paid back his investment so it's
not huge returns right like Sequoia
Scouts Sequoia is one of the biggest
venture capital firms they had a scout
program and they gave 50% to their
scouts you know they were extremely
extremely generous or 45% something like
that so this wasn't that but then again
Sequoia didn't pick me they didn't even
know who the hell I was so I took what I
could get and I realized in order to get
in to get companies if you talk to one
company they want and they usually want
to know what other companies have you
invested in and so I knew I needed to
start building a portfolio of labels so
a bunch of logos that I could point to
and say yep I invested in that company I
invested in that company and that
company you would be in good company if
you were with those companies right
that's the core idea so I said let me
start building this portfolio this guy's
willing to put up all the cash I get a
piece of the upside let's do it so we
wrote the check into lambda school and
I'm very grateful to him for you know
bankrolling me in that and I think it
was a you know fair enough deal
so we invested when it was you know it
was still a pretty expensive deal
because by the time I organized this the
valuation had gone up about three x's so
I lost a 3x returned just in the time it
took me to to get you know sort of a
backer and on the deal if it was just my
own money and I could have invested
after a first phone call I would have
but anyways it's gone up about ten times
in value since then it's that that
investment which is illiquid but that's
the sort of paper valuation of that
company today so that was the first dip
in my feet in the water and I said
alright that was good and I made a deal
with myself which is cool I'm gonna try
to invest in about five to ten companies
per year this is what I might my goal
was I said but you know I think five is
the right sweet spot and unless I'm you
know if I have free time I'll go to ten
a year but I'll do five a year and
whether it's my own money or other
people's money now I'm thinking of
myself in his invent as an investor so
that'd be the first thing I would say to
you guys is if you ever want to invest
if you ever want to be an angel investor
and play this extremely high-risk
high-reward game of startup investing
the the number one advice I would give
to you is don't wait till you're rich to
do it because at that point you know the
financial returns it'll just be a part
of a broader portfolio it's not gonna be
that exciting but if you really want to
do this I start thinking of yourself as
an investor from day one and find ways
to access the capital there are ton of
people out there with capital myself
included who would love for you to be
bringing them deal flow and would
happily give you carry on any deal that
they invest in I remember there was a
guy named Suroosh who is a 13 year old
kid living in Canada and he used to use
our product we built this website called
blab it's like kind of this zoom type of
product he used to get blab all the time
and he was like he came to me and he
said hey I want to I don't remember what
our arrangement was but basically I told
him I said you want to learn about this
stuff I want you to go scout out three
companies a week email me the best one
you know the best one that you saw and
why you think it would be a good
investment why you think would be a bad
investment in your kind of overall
recommendation and one of those
companies now several years later he's I
think 20 years old now so seven years
later the very first company he sent me
is a company called
ply board that just raise money at a 1.1
billion dollar valuation he brought that
email back up to me emailed me again
being like hey why didn't you invest in
this thing I told you to I was like I
know you're 13 I didn't believe you but
yet there's a bunch of examples like
that where you can bring deals to other
people and if they invest you can get
karey and you could bring it to multiple
people so you don't have to be exclusive
with any one person you could say great
these five people all agree that if I
bring them a great deal they'll give me
a slice to the upside great you could
you could do that with five five
different more established investors in
any given time okay enough on that
[Music]
[Applause]